myths are about the queen's guards myth
one we're not allowed to move myth two
that we are not real soldiers
myth three that we are not allowed to
talk if these myths were true we
wouldn't be able to carry out our job as
a guardsman
have you ever wondered what a soldier
eats in the field in front of me i've
got my next 24 hours of rations let's
have a look
for breakfast i'm having some natural
muesli just throwing a bit of water
that's good to go
for lunch we have some bean and pasta
salad this can be eaten hot or cold
my dinner i'll be having a vegetable
corner and a nice cherry turnover as a
puddin
the ration also comes with a bunch of
snacks such as fruit juice
peanuts
biscuit browns
oat biscuits
and a nice cereal bar to chow all down
come to the spork and afterwards you
might need a bit of toilet roll
this is just one of the menus there's
loads of others so tomorrow i'll be
having something different
did you know when the queen is in
residence there are four guardsmen out
on sag instead of two
outside the next
oh
what are you doing
[Laughter]
this is part one of army slang
uh buck sheets so buck shoes when you
get something for free so for example um
someone has just left i just got this
game off of them buckshie
gipping so giffins when something's
horrible or hard so for example if you
just done a circuit your circuit is
skipping
this is the last one of part one so gash
for example
so i've just picked up the gas
did you know the caramel on horseback
got high points during the inspection
and the cavalry on a foot didn't do so
well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chad
praise god
you